uh to this fourth day of the
computational phase transitions workshop
uh we have an amazing program also today
and we will start with samantha petty
from
harvard will tell us about
hard spheres or are the disks and
please thanks for introduction
[Music]
he see my screen
okay um today i'll be talking about
correlation decay for hard spheres via
markov chains
um and what i'll be talking about today
is joint work with tyler helmuth and
will perkins
and the paper corresponding to it is
here on the archive with the same name
as the talk
so i'll start by talking about the hard
sphere model
and then discuss what it means if this
model were to have a phase transition
then i'll talk about sampling from this
model with markov chains
and i'll talk about our results compare
them to previous results and
talk about why phase transitions and
markov chains are related
in this context and i'll end with a
proof
outline showing why the markov chain
we're going to consider is fast mixing
in certain ranges
so i'll start with the hard sphere model
or even one step back what's a sphere
packing
so we say a sphere packing
of a set lambda is a set of mutually
non-overlapping spheres contained in the
set
so here our spheres are in two-dimension
they're disks
and this is a packing because none of
these two disks overlap
so it's fine if you want to think about
the entire talk in two dimensions but
everything we do
is going to be in d dimensions
um why are sphere packings of interest
well there's many reasons
um here are just a few so the one that
sort of got me hooked in the sphere
world um
is that sphere fractions are so easy to
define and yet so poorly understood like
we can
easily explain what it means but the
sphere is in space in two dimensions
three dimensions
in high dimensions but despite how easy
it is to define the model we don't know
much about it
in the sense of we don't know what dense
packings look like in high dimensions
and we don't even know what the correct
density is
asymptotically for how dense we can pack
spheres
sphere packings are also of interest to
coding theory if you're sending
signals and you want to
make sure all the possible messages you
could be sending are far apart so that
if they get
some noise they don't intersect you'd
want to use a sphere packing for that
um and a historical note is the hard
sphere model was one of the first
things people try to simulate with
markov chain monte carlo
so today i'll be focusing on the hard
sphere model
the hard sphere model is a probability
distribution over sphere packings
defined with the following properties
and parameters
so the parameters are capital lambda
which is
the space that we have our sphere
packing in so here it's a box
and the fugacity parameter um so all of
our spheres must
lie entirely in the box we have the
property that all sphere packings with
the same number of spheres are equally
likely
and we have the the fugacity parameter
lambda controls
how packed we want a typical
configuration so
a higher fugacity favors packings with
more spheres
but formally the hard sphere model is a
probability
measure mu on the set lambda with
fugacity parameter
lambda and it's defined by conditioning
a poisson point process of intensity
lambda on the set and we're conditioning
this on the events that the points are
at least pairwise distance to r so that
means that
our spheres aren't overlapping and they
need to be at least distance r from the
boundaries so
they're contained in the set
um wait any questions about the model
okay now i'll talk like in the high
level about
um the concept of decay of correlations
in particular how we can think about it
with reference to the hard sphere model
so we'd say that the heart sphere model
exhibits decay of correlations
if fixing a sphere in some area
here so say we fix this sphere here
hardly affects
the probability that there's a sphere at
a distant point y
so as an example this isn't the hard
sphere model oops
but imagine we had some distribution
over sphere packing that looks really
random
and we had a different distribution
where you picked this sphere packing
this probability half in this sphere
packing with probability half
we'd say that there's no decay of
correlations over here
because if there's a sphere here you
know you must be in this packing you
know there's a sphere over here if
there's not a sphere here you know
you're in this packing and there's not a
sphere here
so it's no decay of correlations whereas
on this side
we have decay of correlations because if
i tell you there's a sphere
in this corner it doesn't really tell
you whether or not there's going to be a
sphere up in the other corner
and likewise if i tell you there's not a
sphere you don't really know
so at a high level that's what you
should think about
behave correlations means one point way
over here doesn't really tell you about
what's happening far away
so the conjecture we can frame the
conjectured phase transition for the
hard sphere model
in terms of this so the conjecture is
that there's a disordered phase
so um in this phase when you sample from
the model
everything kind of looks spread out in
random you'd have this decay of
correlations
and then if there's a phase transition
as we increase that fugacity parameter
lambda
and our model starts to favor sphere
packings with more and more spheres
all of a sudden we'd have a point where
now we have a crystalline phase and
there'd be no decay of correlations in
this phase
another way of formulating this is the
disorder phase is the unique infinite
volumes good measure and the
crystalline phase would be the
non-unique infinite volume gibbs measure
so it's an open question whether or not
there is a phase transition in the hard
sphere model and arbitrary dimensions
so what this would mean is that this
critical value
is less than infinity that there's some
point where we have disordered and
crystalline
if there is no phase transition we would
just say this critical point equals
infinity
it's known that there's a critical point
in one dimension
it's conjectured by physicists that
there's a uh
sorry one dimension um no phase
transition
conjectured by physicists in two
dimensions that um
there also is no space transition and in
three dimensions and above
or actually i'm not sure about it in
three dimensions conjectures that there
is a phase transition
so um even though there's conjectures
the jury's still somewhat out on
on these things um we'll also talk today
a little bit about the critical density
which is
the expected density of a packing drawn
from the hard sphere model
um at the critical fugacity
oh yes if you go back to slides there
one slide
so here you're saying there is no phase
transition conjecture is that there's no
phase transition in two dimensions but
these two pictures look
very different to me so uh what can you
explain a little bit more why
um so it just hasn't been proven
that there is or is not um some people
have some intuition
that there might be a space transition
but i think people
don't know okay
are you gonna define formally what it
means to be a phase transition
um in
we i'm not gonna cover it specifically
and i didn't have it specifically on a
slide but it's um the unique or
non-unique infinite volume gives
measures how we've treated it in the
paper
um for what it's worth i think that
the physicists believe that there is a
phase transition in two dimensions but
that it's of a somewhat
different kind but i don't want to take
any more of your time
yeah there's something with the um
angles happening
there yeah i i'll i'll save that if we
have time at the end i don't know too
much
about that okay
so our goal is to drive improved lower
bounds on the critical fugacity and the
critical density by
analyzing markov chains okay so
this audience i don't really need to
talk about what a markov chain is um
but we want to come up with a markov
chain that's rapidly mixing so if you
take a lot of samples from it
um if we look at like the teeth sample
it's going to look
like it was drawn from the hard sphere
model
or something close to it and we want
that to happen for
t that's polynomial and the size of the
input
so the sorry the markov chain we
analyze here for the hard sphere model
is single center dynamics
so we can define them as follows so the
first step
um is to choose a point x uniformly at
random from our set
so say i've chosen the set or this point
x now we'll flip a coin that's weighted
and with probability lambda over one
plus lambda we'll add a center at
the point x and
only if x is not within distance to r of
another center
or it's not about to come out of the
bounding box lambda so if our coin flip
totals try to add and this is our point
x we would have
added a sphere here with the other um
side of the coin with probability one
over one plus lambda we're going to
remove
any centers that are within r of point x
so here there's no other centers so we
wouldn't have done anything
if our point x had instead been this
point and our coin flip totals tried to
add a center we wouldn't because we
can't add a center here
and if our coin folk told us to remove a
center we would have removed this center
here
yielding one a sphere packing with one
less sphere
and it's not too hard to show that the
stationary distribution of the smart cop
chain is indeed the hard sphere model
okay so wait any questions on the
dynamics
okay now i'll talk about a little bit
about our results and
compare them to previous results so
our main theorem is that the single
center dynamics for the hard sphere
model are rapidly mixing
for fugacity parameters strictly less
than two to the minus d plus one
and we can use this result to
achieve the best known lower bounds on
the critical fugacity
and the critical density so our critical
fugacity lower bound is 2 to the minus d
plus 1
and our critical density lower bound is
2 3 to the minus d
or about .85 plus a little term
to the minus d so our results don't tell
us about whether or not there is a phase
transition but they do say if there is a
phase transition it occurs above these
fugacity parameters
so i'm going to focus mostly on this
talk on
how we prove this theorem but i want to
quickly describe how we
go from this theorem to these new lower
bounds
so for this uh we're going to draw the
connection between markov chains and
phase transitions
so if a markov chain is rapidly mixing
we can think of that as being after
enough steps a sample from the markov
chain looks like it came from
the desired stationary distribution
and this implies a property called
optimal temporal mixing
optimal temporal mixing you can think of
as being
after enough steps the total variation
distance between two instances
of a markov chain is small so this makes
sense if your markov chain is always
going to go towards the hard sphere
model
distribution and you start two markov
chains and they're both going towards
the hardest to your model of course
they're going to be
going towards each other um then we show
that optimal temporal
mixing implies strong spatial mixing for
the hard sphere model and single center
dynamics
so strong spatial mixing is saying that
if
you have a set a subset within the place
you're sphere packing we'll call that
lambda prime
and lambda prime is far from the
boundary of lambda um it's saying that
if you fix spheres on the boundary
whatever is happening on the boundary of
lambda
hardly influences the hard sphere model
restricted to
the smaller set land of prime this is
like a decay of correlations
so we show this property and strong
spatial mixing implies the uniqueness of
the infinite volume
limit which is how we're defining this
context that the phase transition has
not yet happened
so following the chain of logic if the
single center dynamics for the markov
chain is rapidly mixing for lambda less
than
two to the um minus d plus one
then the critical value is also above
this point
okay yeah uh on the previous slide i
thought
uh this was the if i'm on the strong
spatial mixing no
there we go i thought this strong this
is the definition of this
spatial mixing and strong spatial mixing
means
also that you condition on some other
sides close to the boundary or not close
to the boundary to have a particular
occupancy
uh pattern uh so uh
this is just saying that the boundary
doesn't influence what's in it deep
inside
and strong spatial mixing means also
that
it it happens when in addition some
other sites are fixed to a particular
am i um so what i mean here by boundary
conditions
is that um i tried to highlight it
didn't work um
boundary conditions is that so we're
saying lambda is the boundary and then
we've said okay like this sphere is
living close to the boundary and stuck
and we're conditioning our probability
distribution that like these specific
spheres on the boundary
so i think i'm talking about the same
thing but it maybe wasn't clear from the
way i said it
maybe i mean i maybe answered david's
question which is yeah lambda prime can
be any
set and so what happens with uh spheres
in the heart sphere model you cut away
volume
and so it actually is the same but in
the strong spatial mixing doesn't need
to be far from the boundary this
set that you fix it could be close to
the boundary outside
yeah yeah but this lambda prime can be
any set it doesn't have to be a box
and so that accounts for a sphere is
placed
anywhere inside the big box
okay that's okay that's good enough
thank you okay
um oh sorry this slide so um these are
the best known lower bounds so in 2007
the cluster expansion
approach gave a lower bound of um
one over e to the minus d and then
more recently basambulin percolation
gave a lower bound of
one plus a little one term to the minus
d
and we improve on this by a factor of
two and remove the asymptotic part
to the minus d plus one um using our
markov chain in this equivalence
so um oh go ahead i have a question so
does does your method imply exponential
decay of correlation so the correlation
decays like
e to the minus the distance from from
the
you know boundary or or i believe it's e
to the minus distance from the boundary
well you can
correct me if i'm misremembering yeah
that's right exponential decay
because this is related to what chris
mentioned before
in two dimension i think the conjunction
is that there is a phase transition
between exponential and polynomial decay
i mean it's not a phase transition in
the sense of non-uniqueness of gibbs
measure but visibility's transition
i agree so in that sense you will
you will lower bound that phase
transition
yeah there should be an asterisk on the
phase transition i'm i'm talking about
just the phase two interesting that the
uh infinite volume gives measure
um in two dimensions a little bit more
has been done
in the specific other cases um in our
bound also is the best known lower bound
for two dimensions which is
now a half um
so i also like to compare um
our markov chain to other ways of
sampling from the hard sphere model and
sphere-like models so i'll first
talk a little bit about the canonical
sphere model so this is a different
model than the hard sphere model
because you have a fixed number of
spheres so it's like conditioning
the hard sphere model on the number of
spheres so it's saying uniformly over
all sphere packets with case spheres
let's pick one
um and that has been uh studied
recently so kanan mahoney and montenegro
in 2003
showed that a single particle global
move markov chain is fast mixing
for densities below two to the minus d
minus one
and then more recently um in two
dimensions
he's more improved this improves the
analysis
of this markov chain and showed that
it's rapidly mixing for densities below
0.154
so to put this in context earlier i said
our results in terms of the fugacity
where it's has mixing but that
corresponds to
density below two thirds the two thirds
times to the minus d
um which is about or and and this other
bound um which comes out to be
less than a six for two dimensions
the hard sphere model itself has also
been sampling from the heart
sphere model itself uh has also been
studying study
so going back to the fugacity parameter
the um
previous previous workshop that partial
rejection sampling
is efficient for lambda less than 0.23
in two dimensions and so our
bound of a half is improves that
okay so for the last part of the talk
i'll talk through
how we showed that this particular
single center and dynamics markov chain
is fast mixing so
here's the theorem from before fast
mixing for lambda less than two to the
minus d plus one
um so our proof outline we follow boobly
and dyer's path coupling approach
so we define a metric d between pairs of
configurations
and then we show that for any pair of
configurations that differ by one sphere
there's a coupling of the markov chain
so the expected change in this distance
is negative
so um
the key idea for this approach is
extending the state space
and this is an idea we got from
vigoda's 2001 work on the mixing time of
global dynamics on the hardcore model
on body degree graphs so for those who
might not be familiar the
hardcore model is sampling independent
sets on graphs
so it's a very similar flavor to sphere
packings because you're trying to
sample things that are mutually far
apart um
so he found that by extending his state
space instead of
looking at a markov chain over
independent sets he looked at a markov
chain over
sets of vertices by doing so he was able
to show that
global dynamics
has a mixing time of order n log n for a
particular
value of lambda as a function of the
degree of
the graph so we do a similar thing we
change the state space from sets of
packings
to sets of centers
we don't do all sets of centers we're
interested in sets of centers such that
each point of our set is covered by at
most two spheres
so here okay i've changed my lan
my set lambda before usually was a box
now it's a circle
and this is an example clearly not of a
sphere packing because my two spheres
are overlapping
but it is an example of a configuration
in
our extended state space um
because it's each point in our
set is only covered by zero one or two
spheres
and we can say that a mix
the mixing time of our markov chain on
this state space this extended state
space is an upper bound
on the mixing time of the markov chain
on the
space we actually care about and since
if we start in the space we care about
if we start with the packing the single
center dynamics will always
keep us in a packing and we can use this
as an upper bound
so with the path coupling approach we
need to define a pre-metric
so our pre-metric is going to be defined
on pairs of configurations that differ
by one sphere
so here we have x and then we have x
with like an extra sphere so that sphere
is v
and we're going to define what it what
the distance between this
uh configuration and this configuration
is
um for this we need a notion of block
volume um
intuitively block volume is points in
the configuration where you cannot add
centers
so here the block volume is everything
in blue so all blue points you couldn't
add a center there because you'd be
either
going outside the boundary or
overlapping with another sphere
and then we need the notion of an
occupied neighborhood so
we say an occupied neighborhood of a
vertex v with respect to the rest of the
packing x
is going to be how much of its chi
neighborhood is blocked volume which is
the intersection
um okay the the size of the intersection
i'm missing the cardinality bar center
okay so
um or no i guess the cardinality bars
are over here sorry
so the distance between these two
packings is going to be two to the
d minus a constant that we choose wisely
um
times the volume of this occupied
neighborhood
um and then the algebra works out when
we use this
this value of c
so i want to give a little bit of
intuition for why
we need this extended state space um for
our analysis to work out
so we have defined um our pre-metric on
pairs of configurations in our extended
state space that differ
by one sphere and d is going to be the
corresponding shortest path metric
on um the state space the extended state
space
so i want to show you why if we let d be
the corresponding
shortest path metric and we're allowed
to use our extended state space that
actually gives us a different distances
than if we have to use the
smaller state space of packings
so here i'm back to circles being what
we're putting our sphere packing in
and so here's two different sphere
packings um and if i wanted to define
the distance
between them i could use the triangle
inequality
and i'm going to use the
distance to this particular
configuration with the overlap
so the distance here
is the sum of these two terms the path
of length two you're going from this
sphere back into this one and then from
this one to this one
and um based on our metric from before
it's two to the d um minus the occupied
uh volume and so it's gonna be strictly
less than two to the d
plus one because we have two two terms
that are less than two to the d
um now we could let the state space or
now we can do a thought experiment like
what if we didn't extend our
state space now if we wanted to find the
distance between these two
um configurations the only possible way
to do that
um in our graph of all the states is to
go down to the state with no
spheres and now this distance according
to our premetric is
going to be 2 to the d as well as this
one so
if our state space is different we
actually have different
um metrics d
okay so that was a reminder okay so
the markov chain um is going to reduce
expected distance in each iteration so
if you have a configuration x
and then a configuration y where y just
has one more sphere than x
and now we're gonna couple one move in
the markov chain in each of these
configurations
a quick question so um
maybe maybe this was already clear but
so does the distance between two states
go to zero
as the distance between the two the two
sphere centers
goes to zero so
i like to think about comparing um a
configuration
two configurations where one has an
extra sphere as opposed to the other
but i think
what you would do for the in-between
would be having an overlapping sphere
i need to think more about that um
i can think more about that and get back
to you um
okay just to finish um so we're looking
at the expected distance
and how it changes once we apply one
step of the markov chain
um and so the analysis that we need to
do
some case work so we need to consider we
have x
or our one configuration has spheres x
and another has x plus an extra sphere
and so when that extra sphere is removed
everything's great everything's coupled
and that decreases the distance
we could have the case where center is
added to the configuration x but not
added to the configuration y
because it's blocked by that center of v
and now we have to use a triangle
inequality to estimate
this distance here and then we could
have the situation where a center is
added to both
x and y or a center is removed from both
x and y
and in those cases we have to analyze
how the
occupied volume changes to see how the
distance changes
but um we worked out that this is a
upper bound on the change in distance
and it's going to be less than zero
specifically in the range of lambda that
we want
okay um sorry for going a little over
thanks everyone
um any questions
any questions i i have a question so
um thanks for the great talk i think
this is lovely work
um so one question that you've probably
anticipated
is that for independence sets on graphs
there's this
it almost feels like a duality between
uh
studying very simple markov chains with
a fancier metric
and studying slightly fancier markov
chains that have more moves
and so it seems like the analogous move
here is a slide move where i'm allowed
to
take a a disc and shift it slightly
and so i mean is there an analogous
thing here to the case of independent
sets on graphs where we can
argue that if i do those slide moves at
a certain rate
where maybe the rate depends on the
distance i'm sliding it
um or the the symmetric uh
the size of the symmetric difference in
the neighborhoods before and after
that that would also mix quickly up to
the same point
uh i haven't thought too much into that
but that seems like a
very interesting direction to go in
so i have a question for perhaps
what is known about top balance
say that again what is known about upper
bounds or lambda c
oh um well if we had an upper bound we
would
know that there exists the phase
transition so i think
nothing other than that it doesn't exist
in one dimension
and what is what is the difficulty there
normally lower bounds on mixing times
are easier than
upper bounds
i haven't thought too much about the
upper bound problem i don't have as much
intuition there
i mean isn't there something like a
player's argument
i mean normally in the models and grids
there is players are covered
there's infinitely many ground states
here right
yeah i understand that the piles are
argument doesn't work
it's a it's a great open problem but
that doesn't mean i mean
uh you can do pyrex argument for uh
models with continuous spins
right in only like wooden rollins and
which is a different type of phase
transition
uh cannot you do line model
in in three dimensions cannot improve
the existence of a phase transition with
pairs algorithm
oh i see you mean on a lattice
other questions
okay i'll ask one more question is there
any heuristic estimate of what is lambda
c
um how far you are from the real right
from the sea
my physicists must have i mean have i
know have simulated this to death
right so yeah i'm not sure i'll see if
anyone in the audience knows um
i i will say that in our analysis there
were sort of like a lot of like worst
case thing
upper bound type things that it's like
this isn't going to be generally when
you're moving a sphere or something
this drastic isn't happening so it
definitely doesn't feel like it's the
tight um lower bound
um but if anyone knows any more please
chime in
i mean the all the all the bounds that i
saw in your review were two to the minus
d
times a constant right so i wonder
whether at least the two minus
two to the minus d factor is correct or
no
according to the cavity method that is
correct so francesco zamponi
applies cavity method to hard spheres
and high dimensions
and this two to the minus d is correct
so
um the first phase transition should
happen at i think some
uh d times two to the minus d or
something like that but the two to the
minus d
has to be there
i i just wanted to mention the the
situation in two dimensions
is you know maybe a very hard but still
a really interesting open problem
so as andrea referred to there's a
classic physics argument that says that
we can't literally have a solid crystal
in two dimensions
in other words as you get farther away
from the origin
there is some spatial jiggle so that
very far away the even if i conditioned
on a disk at the origin the probability
distribution would get broader and
broader as i go farther away
but there's this conjectured hexatic
phase which is
quite mysterious which says that if i
condition
on the angle between two
nearby disks at the origin that this
information
does survive at arbitrarily long
distances in other words if you were to
plot
a histogram of the angles between nearby
things
you would see six peaks as you go around
the circle
corresponding to a roughly close packing
and numerically this does seem to
persist
so in that sense i guess you wouldn't
have uniqueness of the gibbs measure
because you would have won
gibbs measure for each uh rotation
um so anyway
but i don't remember i mean is does the
anger really persist or it decays
polynomially right because i remember
there is the
mermain wagner theorem that should say
that you know the angle
should go well i i i need to look up
the latest i i need to look up the
papers by verner crouton company
um but i thought i thought that that
information could actually persist at
long range but i
i could be wrong stupid question what is
angle here i mean these are spheres so i
guess your
the alignment of the of the centers
corresponding to the horizontal is that
what you mean by angle
i i just mean if if you so if you do a
numerical experiment
where you take say um
the let's put a disc at the origin
and then you let everything else move
around and then
you look at the angles of say the
closest other disc
to the origin okay right
so if you were at fairly high densities
you would expect kind of roughly a
triangular close
packing yeah and so if you just do this
as a numerical experiment and i i know
it's how close is close enough blah blah
blah but you see these peaks at
uh you know at multiples of 60 degrees
shifted somehow
i see yeah so there is a related
question in the q a
box that asks how do this 2d
phase transition relate to the cost of
its tourist transition of 2d superfluid
vortices and i think it's similar in the
sense that i don't know anybody knows
more than me but
to these superfluid vortices are like
hardcore spheres i mean they cannot
penetrate each other
yeah and so perhaps i mean you know what
i remember is that there is
yeah you can see the angle and then this
angle
according to nelson theory of a
coastal storage phrase transitioning
says they start decaying
polynomially but not exponential
but okay i think we have five more
minutes in the program
anybody else wants to ask something
a quick question is there some
meaningful model
for a tree version of this model that
would be a
reasonable proxy for um
model in rt just like uh regulatory is a
reasonable proxy
or is it reasonable to
for some purposes for some people so
this is what will was referring to right
i mean uh francesco zamponi has studied
i mean it has not done exactly on a tree
but it has done it
on uh on zd on zd on on
rd using a large dimensional limit
and there is some kind of mean field
theory of this
and then there is another model that is
you can do
hard spheres in in on a lattice right
and then generalize this to a three
there was a yeah okay there are a bunch
of models
but hard spheres on the lattice is not
the independent set and a lot it's just
something else
because independent set on the lattice
it behaves completely differently
you can set a radius right
on the lattice so you can have centers
centers
so david i have one other answer to your
question which is a very new paper i
have with marcus michelin we do
we construct some infinite tree-like
object to do recursions
and so we can get a factor e
and so we can basically get the white's
type bound
for hard spheres but also a bunch of
repulsive point processes
um and and there's some natural like
tree
object there that's very strange it like
is infinitely branching
but you can do the white's argument
essentially and get another factor e
so it's e over two to the d e over two
to the d
right where d is some branching please
sum the dimension dimension
oh so this is done on the ladder on what
hard spheres or or other repulsive point
processes
but you you there's a recursion for the
density of the process that is
like the white's recursion and it and
then some weird tree object
so this is an analysis of the same model
in rd but in which
you know in the analysis you use a tree
object
yeah but you could also do the point
process on this weird tree object
that's it okay nice
interesting okay
well let's thank the speaker again hi
yeah absolutely
you're listening and uh
the next speaker is i guess will